[Musique]
maman
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire celles et ceux qui
voudraient interdire la chasse
appartiennent en général est de
catégorie ce sont soit des défenseurs
des animaux soient des défenseurs des
promeneurs innocents qui risque de
prendre une balle perdue c'est encore
arriver un jeune homme de 25 ans tuée
dans le lot et plus récemment un
automobiliste de 67 en bretagne mais les
défenseurs de la chacun de la chasse
invoquent eux aussi leur amour des
animaux de la nature des traditions du
folklore et leur amour de l'humanité
l'homme ayant chasser pour se nourrir
depuis ses origines alors pour ou contre
l'interdiction de la chasse c'est un
débat qui revient régulièrement dans
l'actualité notamment les années
d'élections la france compte entre 1 et
3 millions de chasseurs nous avons donc
invité helens oui vous êtes candidate à
la prochaine élection présidentielle du
parti animalistes dont vous êtes co
fondatrice et co-présidente c'est vous
qui avait conduit la liste animalistes
qui a recueilli 2,2 pour cent des
suffrages exprimés aux dernières
européennes
l'interdiction pure et simple de la
chasse ça fait carrément partie de votre
programme saignements oui et pourquoi
pas parce que pour des raisons éthiques
il nous apparaît pas nécessaire et bien
fondé de continuer à tuer des animaux
sachant que quand on parle de la chasse
en fait la moitié des animaux qui sont
tués à la chasse sont élevées lâcher et
servent de cibles vivantes et c'est
inacceptable et il y à d'autres moyens
par rapport aux dégâts par exemple aux
cultures qui sont souvent invoqués pour
justifier la chasse il ya d'autres
moyens de les prévenir plutôt que de
toujours s'en prendre aux animaux eddie
puyjalon vous êtes le président du
mouvement de la ruralité qui entend
défendre le monde rural une écologie de
bon sens là je vous cite les traditions
et la vie dans nos campagnes le
mouvement de la ruralité c'est le
nouveau nom de chasse pêche nature et
traditions dont le président avait fait
4 23% des voix à la présidentielle en
2002 vous défendez toujours la chasse
bien évidemment et pourquoi parce que
d'abord je suis chasseur que j'adore
cette relation à la nature et puis la
convivialité un esprit
social que j'ai toujours connu dans ma
commune et que je trouvais qu'on avait
rien de trouvé de mieux comme relations
entre les hommes et les femmes dans les
territoires la relation aux animaux la
connaissance des choses de la vie et
donc
j'ai pas culpabiliser parce que je
mangeais faisant un canard le lièvre et
voilà je trouve que derrière tout ça
sociétalement ce qui me donne des leçons
je les trouve triste voilà je suis
quelqu'un d'heureux thomas lepeltier
vous êtes historien et philosophe des
sciences vous avez publié récemment big
bang histoire critique d'une idée chez
gallimard mais vous êtes également
chercheur en éthique animal c'est en
tant que tels que vous avez co édité
plaidoyer pour une viande sans animal ou
pu fait que vous avez écrit les vegan au
pouvoir qui ressort en édition augmentée
aux éditions le poly le pommier fait
également partie des signataires de la
tribune demandant l'arrêt de la chasse à
courre et vous êtes à l'origine d'une
autre tribune devant tant d assises
nationales de la condition animale alors
antispécistes vegan vous devez
logiquement être pour l'interdiction
totale de la chasse je pense que oui
futur je suis contre l'interdiction de
la chasse mais j'ajouterai caven humour
l'interdiction des chats je suis pour
l'interdiction à face et je vais très
bien je crois qu on est tous d'accord
pour éviter la cruauté envers les
animaux et de tuer des animaux ou les
faire souffrir sans nécessité donc je
pense qu'on peut tous s'entendre sur le
fait qu'il faudrait interdire la chasse
de loisirs que finalement si et c'est
une chasse de loisirs c'est donc
justement uniquement pour s'amuser et je
pense que s'ils ont des contre la
cruauté envers les animaux on doit être
contre cette forme de chasse il est
plutôt pour la chasse de loisirs or
justement l'occasion de rectifier en
discuter et christophe bâti que vous
vous êtes socio anthropologue spécialisé
dans la chasse et la ruralité chercheurs
enseigne à l'université picardie à
amiens on vous doit notamment regard sur
l'un certains politiques à l'harmattan
vous vous défendez les chasseurs voulait
défendiez déjà dans votre thèse de
doctorat en 2007 sur les pratiques de
chasse comme affirmation politique du
principe de tony vous ne m'avez pas lu
dans chaque sens où je me suis dit en
lisant le lotissement s'il doit défendre
les chasseurs mais peut-être non non
c'est du moins alors si j'avais pu
choisir ma place ici sur le plateau je
me sens villabon mais il fallait bien
mettre quelque part mais je me serais
mis là en fait je pensais que vous allez
me poser la question comme on me l'a
toujours posée y compris mes collègues
universitaires de savoir si moi-même
j'avais
pratiqué alors j'en répondrai avec
beaucoup d'humour heureusement que j'ai
pas travailler sur la prostitution je
sais pas quel
donc non je défends pas j'attaque pas
jolie peau ni contre j'ai jamais
pratiqué j'aurais pu parce que je me
suis posé la question de savoir si je
raté quelque chose dans mon étude mais
je resterai imperturbablement et je le
défendrai comme au point de mes
étudiants dans le refus total au nom de
la science de se positionner sur ces
questions donc ni pour ni contre
l'arraisonnement évidemment parfait
alors ma première question revenant sur
les accidents de chasse parce qu'en 20
ans ils ont fait environ 15 400 morts
sans compter les blessés parce qu'il ya
environ cent cinquante huit accidents
par an en moyenne à collectif a été créé
à la suite de la mort de morgane qui
n'en décembre dernier tue
accidentellement par un chasseur alors
qu'il coupait du bois dans son jardin il
demande l'interdiction de la chasse les
mercredis et les jeudis et les dimanches
pardon hilare et 7,7 cette pétition a
recueilli plus de cent mille signatures
elle a été transmise au sénat
ça veut ça fait partie alors ceux qui
demandent l'interdiction de la chasse
mais certains jours notamment le
mercredi et le dimanche parce que
mercredi c'est le jour des enfants le
dimanche c'est le jour des familles
ça comme ça pourrait être un bon début
pour vous alors c'est un bon début mais
c'est pas suffisant parce qu'on voit
bien que les accidents de chasse
interviennent quelles que soient les
jours de la semaine et qu'ils sont
effectivement nombreux donc oui c est en
plus surtout c'est que la plupart des
personnes en territoire rural dont je
suis 84% selon un dernier sondage se
sentent en insécurité à cause de la
chasse donc un vrai problème
d'insécurité à cause de la chasse à la
campagne eddie puyjalon le fait qu'il
ait tant de gens qui sentent en
insécurité
ça devrait
c'est pas que ça me fait sourire parce
que c'est un sujet trop trop trop trop
important pour un poids rire en réalité
je le sentiment d'insécurité il me fait
penser au même sentiment d'insécurité
que peuvent avoir les gens milieu rural
qu'en jamais vu un voleur un incendie et
qui se tourner vers l'extrême droite
prétextant qu'ils avaient des exactions
c'est la même chose pour les accidents
c'est à dire comment fait tellement une
version médiatisé qu'aujourd'hui le
sentiment d'insécurité se retrouvent
vis-à-vis des chasseurs je rappellerai
que plus le comble de la chose c'est que
ces accidents qui ont eu lieu fait
baisser considérablement les dernières
années mais l'augmentation des accidents
est arrivé par la faute des animalistes
c'est d'ailleurs qu'on a demandé aux
chasseurs de ne plus pratiquer avec la
chevrotine pour ne pas blesser les
animaux d'utiliser des arme de guerre
d'accord donc l'utilisation d'armes de
guerre d'un des concepts ou aujourd'hui
le mitage du territoire l'arrivée de
nombreux animaux l'obligation de réguler
fait qu'aujourd'hui on utilise des armes
hyper puissante dans des zones
extrêmement sensible et donc il a fallu
former les chasseurs pendant des années
les anime fair du décor pour faire
chuter et malgré tout cet accident mais
même un at-il en ces matières de trop
mais il faut s'imaginer c'est comme si
demain pour la sécurité routière on
disait aux gens au lieu de rouler avec
une quatrième voiture électrique on va
vous mettre une ferrari mais 600 chevaux
vous allez voir de suite comme il valoir
d'accidents est en route et il fallait
maîtriser ça on l'a fait c'est pas
suffisant moi j'ai fait j'ai bien vu que
le président national la fédération a
fait une vidéo pour demain des encore
aux chasseurs d'être extrêmement
responsable je les fais pareil je suis
toujours remonter à chaque fois qu'un
accident de trop parce que c'est notre
responsabilité à chacun mais de venir
dire que 1 million de chasseurs tous les
jours qu'ils pratiquent mettre un ratio
sur ces accidents la disputer j'aimerais
bien qu'on se positionne sur d'autres
accidents de la vie aujourd'hui qui sont
catastrophiques où il ya des milliers de
morts ça ne justifie pas à notre action
mais quand même la focalisation canet
fait on on a bien compris qu'on arrive
en période électorale et que nos amis
des écologistes plus et les animalistes
ben ils se font du beurre de ces choses
là et et moi évidemment je suis peiné
d'avoir ces accidents parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'éducation rural
que j'ai dit c'est aujourd'hui c'est
respecter les usages et moi je vais
pratiquer des formes de chasse il ya des
concours saint-hubert où on explique aux
enfants et à ceux qui viennent pratiquer
la chasse comment la courtoisie le fusil
décharger en l'espace est déjà c'est une
éducation rural qu'il faut avoir et donc
voilà une fois de plus arrêtons il va
encore continuer à essayer de faire des
efforts on va encore taper un peu sur
ceux qui ne font pas mais l'accident
zéro n'existe pas alors savez ces armes
puissantes et je vous le dis mais il
suffit d'une caille ou d'une branche la
balle ne va plus vous avez décidé de la
mettre et donc aujourd'hui on essaie
d'avoir des éléments comme des portables
et des smartphones où on va expliquer où
c'est qu'il y ait lieu de chasse il faut
arriver à informer le plus part des gens
qui se promènent et puis je vous le dis
à force de stigmatiser les gens ce qui
se passe je l'avais vu devant les années
2000 aujourd'hui je vois fleurir des
panneaux certes les gens qui ont des
propriétés privées les forestiers les
agriculteurs qui sont aussi chasseur
disent maintenant c'est fini on va
mettre des panneaux interdiction de
venir la propriété mes soeurs non non
non non atteint aux promeneurs sauf
réservé aux chasseurs ne savait bien que
le discours qui fait sûr il ya plus de
chasseurs en ville de caraquet la
ruralité pour arrêter de dire des
bêtises moi dans mon village tout le
monde sait qui est chasseur le docteur
le boucher charcutier le boulanger tout
le monde sait qui est chasseur
d'inconvenant communes rurales et tu as
tous les propriétaires agriculteurs ont
besoin des chasseurs et croyez bien qu'à
force de monter parce que ils voyaient
de suite les conséquences pictures ces
dégâts l'école etc il ya eu même des
fois son chasseur il préfère avoir une
nature ouverte ce que c'est d'abord
c'est dans notre nature la ruralité chez
moi c'est porte ouverte à tout le monde
et donc c'est le vivre ensemble passe
est cet esprit de fin on est aujourd'hui
en train de fracturer nos sociétés on
avait déjà des problèmes avec les
banlieues etc il a intenté en a rajouté
dans la ruralité avec les chasseurs les
pêcheurs les agriculteurs on irait
qu'aujourd'hui ce monde on se fait
plaisir à monter les gens les uns contre
les autres moi je savais pas mon état
d'esprit est encore une fois de plus
j'espère enfin je pense qu'on peut tous
s'améliorer est arrivé avec un vivre
ensemble dans la nature lnd oui c'est un
peu de votre photo à c'est incroyable en
matière de mauvaise foi je pense qu'on
n'est jamais déçu par les chasseurs
c'est toujours d'un cran supérieur de la
faute des animalistes pour les armes de
chasse est assez incroyable
non évidemment non c'est pas du tout
sérieux s'il ya des armes de chasse
comme le reconnaît monsieur jalons qui
sont dangereuses mais la première des
réactions raisonnée et raisonnable c'est
d'interdire ces armes et d'interdire la
chasse chez vous pour les séquences
extrêmement danger le monde de
l'écologie non non mais attendez et sur
le sentiment d'insécurité je vis à la
campagne j'ai grandi dans un village de
200 habitants je sais très bien que la
plupart des gens ont la peur de la
chasse et se taisent d'une certaine
omerta la campagne je suis bien placé
pour le savoir est que contrairement à
ce que vous dites monsieur pigeon la
moitié des chasseurs qui représente 2%
de la population viennent des villes
donc quand on nous explique que la
ruralité c'est la chasse et j'en suis
l'incarnation évidence non la chasse
n'est pas la ruralité les ruraux aime la
nature et les yeux ruraux sont heureux
parce que monsieur rue monsieur pigeon
est heureux moi aussi je suis heureuse
mais sans chasse que christophe mathy je
n'avais pas certains vieux savez moi je
suis né d'un juno communiqué vous le
connaissez très bien à cubzac-les-ponts
pingouins de bordeaux ou 7,8 reviens moi
il ya 25 ans de ça les gens venaient
avec leurs chiens et leurs fusils
chercher le pain s'arrêter au troquet du
coin à la boucherie personne n'avait
peur d'eux et tout le monde était
heureux de les voir et même je vais vous
dire mieux que ça il y en a qui
attendait qu'il passe pour leur demander
si elles pas un petit faisant ou un
petit pigeon a ramassé ça a été monté de
fil en aiguille et mis en scène par les
par les opposants à la chasse dont le
premier les verts madame voynet on se
rappelle les années 2000 et puis là vous
vous continuez sur ce sujet là croyez
bien qu'aujourd'hui moi je là où je vis
et plus bas en milieu rural plus les
gens n'ont aucune peur de la chasse
parce qu'ils connaissent parfaitement
l'activité chasse et que tout ça c'est
monté de fil en aiguille évidemment
encore une fois de plus je vous dise il
avait pas eu six des dix accidents ne
serait pas alors à socio anthropologue
peut-être nous éclairer sur ce sujet a
simplement 2.2 éléments de réponse tout
à l'heure vous me présentez comme
spécialiste de chasser la réalité en
fait c'est la spatialité vent qui
m'intéresse justement le premier point
c'est celui de la spatialité est ce que
nos sociétés choisies c'est que je ne
prendrai pas position sur cet aspect est
ce qu'elles veulent choisir des espaces
qui sont cliver et soit dans le temps
soit territorialement parlant chacun sa
rivale à chacun sa réserve réserve
temporel ou est ce qu'on choisit au
contraire d'essayer de cohabiter non ces
espaces effectivement il ya un débat sur
le type d'armes puisque un fusil
habituel ça a une portée utile d'à peu
près 30 mètres au grand maximum donc on
n'est pas sur les mêmes débats en
fonction du type d'armes est le mode de
chasse deuxièmement une réponse sur le
plan vraiment temporel cette fois et il
ya tout un débat pour savoir si
effectivement il faudrait interdire à
tel moment où est l autre moment mais ça
pose la question aussi de la présence de
tout ça au même moment et c'est aussi la
question de la rencontre finalement vous
voulez que les enfants et les chasseurs
je reviens rencontré quand ils veulent
je rien mais je me dis simplement qu'il
faut avoir conscience du fait que s'il
ya des impossibilités de rencontre
effectivement on en aura peut-être des
conséquences qui sont difficiles à
évaluer et dont les conséquences sont
pas forcément négatif dans un sens comme
dans l'autre mais en tout cas il faut le
savoir le maillot perrine de
l'interdiction pour certains pour depuis
très longtemps même si nicolas hulot en
premier c'est d'interdire de pratiquer
la chasse le week-end et les jours
fériés et les parts et les périodes
scolaires pour éviter d'avoir une
transmission aux enfants
- écoutez mes enfants et des amis qui
sont pas chasseur bien de pratiquer avec
nous je peux vous dire que je fais pas
du prosélytisme
ils sont heureux de venir il n'y a pas
d'actes de cruauté il ya du plaisir à
être dans la nature avec des images
incroyables et c'est pas les images de
barbarie qu'on voudrait nous faire
passer aujourd'hui la chasse le mercredi
et le dimanche ça revient à interdire la
chasse totalement les gens ils
travaillent la semaine leur seul plaisir
de partir le week-end et monsieur et de
la picardie le gibier d'eau la baie de
somme et c'est ce sont des choses qui se
pratique sur des milliers milieu ans
marié et sert à prévenir il ya personne
est absolument personne à part le
chasseur qui vient là dans ce milieu il
ya aucun risque accidentogène faut être
très clair là-dessus le plus peur ce
sont pas loin des banlieues sur des
battues ou sur du grand gibier où il ya
un peu de proximité avec des promeneurs
des randonneurs et vous avez à d'autres
endroits où la nature il ya pas un chat
qui vient à part les chasseurs et les
pêcheurs très vite un vraiment très
rapidement effectivement il faudrait
peut-être distingué au même niveau de la
distinction entre le type d'armé
l'équipe de mode de chasse le type de
territoire vous avez des territoires qui
sont hyper pâture et si je peux me
permettre l'expression en termes de
pratiques de chasse à quasiment toute la
période de chasse
et vous en avez d'autres ou très
objectivement il ya quelques heures de
chasse dans une semaine donc il faut
distinguer entre les deux parce
qu'effectivement vous entendez un coup
de fusil ça ne veut pas dire que côté de
chez vous on chasse oui donc c'est
vraiment la distinction entre ces
territoires qui est vraiment très
intéressant il ya marc qui chasse la
nuit et où il ya personne
cette question là qui est un peu
difficile et on n'arrivera pas à se
mettre d'accord bien sûr sûr
mais ça ça pourrait déjà réglé sur la
gestion des territoires ça pourrait
peut-être se régler sa part des formes
de référendum finalement pas ce que est
ce que la population rurale veut qu'il y
ait des chasseurs ou pas un référendum
pourrait répondre à cette question
plutôt que croire les paroles des uns ou
des autres mais moi je voudrais un petit
peu comme si on en est là pour débattre
de la chasse arrivés un peu au coeur du
sujet est-ce que la chasse avant tout
avant d'être un moment de convivialité
comme monsieur nous le dit c'est quand
même un acte de mise à mort des animaux
une question avant qu'on arrive à la
mise à mort des animaux qui vous avez
raison et le le scandale pour les uns et
au contraire la potel aussi pour les
autres il ya besoin du permis quand même
le permis de conduire est extrêmement
surveiller contrôler on n'arrête pas de
nous retirer des points de vérifier
qu'on est bien mais le permis de chasse
j'ai l'impression qu'il ne l'est pas et
on se dit ben tiens le chasseur qui dans
un grand moment de convivialité
s'est mis à boire qui se balade avec un
chat avec son fusil il est peut-être
ivre mort non c'est pas personne ne
vient vérifier et on reproche aussi je
savais que les accidents de chasse
jouissent d'une impunité
est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
l'activité chasse est extrêmement
réglementé surveillé par les gardes de
l'office national de la biodiversité
je vais me dire même ceux qui chassent
la nuit ont des visites à minuit dans
leur cabane avec des revolver pointé sur
eux une torche et ont fouillé on
surveille de toute l'activité
cynégétique je peux vous dire qu'à des
gens il ya même des gamins qui ont eu
extrêmement peur sur l'activité battus
et ces obsédés que le responsable de
l'organisation de la chasse un peu de
condamner très lourdement s'il ya des
défauts à la sécurité donc il ya des
amendes mais il ya aussi le tribunal je
vais vous dire qu'aujourd'hui l'activité
de régulation entre guillemets du
sanglier d'autres choses fait qu'il ya
des responsabilités sur chaque
organisateur notamment sur les règles de
sécurité j'ai un souvenir d'un mois
département d'un responsable de chasse
qui n'a pas lu la totalité du texte
réglementaire et qui s'est retrouvé
condamné à la place de celui qui avait
causé l'accident donc il ya des vraiment
des règles très dur et aujourd'hui il va
y avoir donc de la formation et ça se
trouve c'est plutôt pas mal une
formation pour les anciens parce que ce
que je disais tout à l'heure sur la
l'arrivée de ces nouvelles armes par le
fait que les écologie demande et
d'autres armes a nécessité aujourd'hui
une nouvelle formation aux personnes
âgées qui ne connaissait pas cette
pratique il faut aujourd'hui une
formation continue c'est ce qui a été
validé dans la loi chasse je trouve que
c'est une bonne chose rien à ajouter sur
ce cheveu non alors sur la formation
alors sur la question de des règles de
sécurité du contrôle des autorités c'est
faux non seulement il n'y a pas de
sanction il ya que la chasse est une
impunité complète sur les accidents de
chasse non mais attendez regarder les
condamnations je suis avocate je suis
bien passé pour voir il ya donc la
nation il ya les oignons et l'ail petit
rhône avis il ya souvent des relaxes et
le problème souvent qui se pose c'est
que les règles de sécurité ne sont pas
fixés au niveau étatique ou mal fixés ou
très insuffisante ça donne lieu à des
relaxes que l'état a complètement
délégué tous ses pouvoirs aux
fédérations de chasseurs et que l'état
est complaisant que ce soit au niveau de
l'état du haut niveau des départs des
débuts tout dans des préfectures on a
une vraie complaisance avec les
chasseurs qui sont en fait les
préfectures se retrouve des chambres
d'enregistrement par exemple pour les
questions de battues administratives
les battues administratives sont
demandés par les fédérations de
chasseurs le préfet signe comme une
quête est comme une chambre
d'enregistrement et en fait on se
retrouve avec une situation où les
chasseurs font la loi et c'est
absolument insupportable est déconnecté
des territoires parce que tu vois ce
sont des mères qui se plaignent de gros
problèmes dans leur commune notamment
parce que ce sont les nouveaux réunis
les ruraux qui vient d'arriver les néo
ruraux qui se plaignent de dégâts et
donc sorte que l'école tant les
sangliers arrive ce sont effectivement
les maires qui demande à la fédération
via le préfet d'organiser des battues
administratives il ya aussi des endroits
où le grand gibier se trouve en bordure
d'autoroute de zone compliquée avec un
habitat très serré et donc là il faut
des règles et déjà des gens habitués à
faire des battues pour enlever ces
animaux là et croyez bien que c'est un
amusement ce sont des responsabilités
extrêmement sévère parce que le moindre
accident encore une fois de plus va nous
retomber dessus donc là il faut pas dire
tout et n'importe quoi c'est drastique
cetc draconien et les préfets bah tout
et n'importe quoi quand même abusé de
leurs de leur pouvoir et de leur sagesse
alors je vais vous choquer mais sans
provocation vous disiez tout à l'heure
je crois hélas qu on vous mettra pas
d'accord moi j'ai pas envie de vous les
métiers d'accor pour une raison très
simple c'est que sociologiquement
parlant le désaccord on parle pas de
génocide un d'accord le conflit
classique sociologique est nécessaire il
est normal c'est-à-dire dans les normes
dans la mesure où les gens n'ont pas les
mêmes intérêts les mêmes philosophies et
même regard et c'est cette diversité là
aussi qui peut être intéressant je
prêche pour sa chapelle parce que je les
cherche aussi vous prêchez surtout a
convaincu 1 ce n'est pas envie si vous
voulez de d'étudier de l'uniformité bien
sûr c'est plus intéressant pour moi de
voir la diversité mais je pense qu'elle
est révélatrice de quelque chose et donc
le conflit il fait partie des choses et
je vois pas pourquoi on faisait
l'éliminer nommé immeuble le disais
avant moi dès le début du vatican serait
tout à fait d'accord avec cette position
si elle se veut n'est pas sur le dos des
animaux le conflit il est très bien en
société dans un débat s'il ya une
richesse du conflit intellectuelle d'une
certaine manière même à des conflits de
mode de vie ça peut être une certaine
richesse dans la vie en société mais là
où tu quand même des millions d'animaux
chaque année et c'est ça la question
fondamentale donc est ce qu'on peut se
permettre d'avoir un petit conflit pour
animer des débats de temps en temps sur
le dos des animaux moi moi
personnellement je ne crois pas et c'est
ça le coeur du débat peut-on est la
question fondamentale au coeur de la
chasse la chasse de loisirs en
particulier parce qu'après on peut voir
il est des situations bien sûr difficile
où il ya une gestion de la faune sauvage
à à mettre en place mais la chasse de
loisirs c'est se donner le droit de tuer
et de faire souffrir des animaux pour
salomon très bien parce que moi j'arrive
du congo j'ai passé quelques semaines au
congo a travaillé sur ce qu'on appelait
dans le temps les pygmées autrement dit
la débâcle et on y est en train de les
expulser de la forêt alors j'ai pas à
prendre partie pour eux je constate
simplement qu actuellement tout est fait
pour faire en sorte qu'au nom de la
biodiversité la conservation de
réservoirs de carbone liées à des
investissements et un désintérêt hic
prix de ces peuples anciennement
chasseurs cueilleurs qu'on a cherché à
sédentariser de la forêt mais c'est vrai
dans une vraie question parce que toutes
les réserves en afrique oui tu ta des
masaï avec ses cartes et finalement si
mon collègue jean temps mais son
argument dit ça se fait sur les animaux
dans ce cas là c'est l'argument
d'autorité qui fait qu'il n'ya plus de
débat il ya plus de conflit il ya plus
de possibilités de conflits le conflit
doit disparaître ne serait ce que parce
que les animaux sont en cause or
effectivement on pourrait retourner la
perspective et c'est la situation à
laquelle je me suivent c'est à laquelle
je me suis retrouvé face à des individus
qui effectivement défend l'idée de
pouvoir continuer et seront patrimoniale
iseo titre justement qui sont chasseurs
cueilleurs si ce n'est qu'ils ne peuvent
plus exercer au niveau des terrils sens
ce doit être à peu près la même exemple
que au pôle nord avec les inuits on a
voulu tourner vers une autre
alimentation en les sédentarisent on est
et on s'est aperçu que les pathologies
qu'ils avaient et que la meilleure
qualité de vie pour eux c'était de
revenir les pêcheurs chasseurs qu'ils
étaient avec un prélèvement naturel et
raisonnée et qui en faisait qui avait
pas d'algues de tokyo
mais ça fait partie de l'acceptabilité
voulait faire une généralité prenez des
gens qui voudraient pour les transposer
l'ambiance qui ne sont pas bien des gens
qui voient les amérindiens y chasser le
canard comme jeudi avait du curé et
d'assez haut que c'est beau la nature et
monsieur et puis nous ici à casablanca
28 est-ce que je les mange bien sûr et
je vous dis je pense et je vous demande
si vous ne mangez que les animaux vous
tue à la chatte et ça m'a seulement je
m'appelle et me voilà donc de la
bazadaise de limousines je mange du foie
gras je suis amoureux de la gastronomie
ce matin c'est dans la logique du
chasseur cueilleur monsieur mais si je
ramasse des champignons je baise moi son
genre il des joueurs en fait non mais ça
ne tient pas du coup votre réseau mais
sinon excuse moi j'ai la place de
l'homme dans la nature en tant que
chasseur pêcheur cueilleurs pour moi
c'est quelque chose d'un équilibre non
mais tu vois seulement nous avions un
super matinée c'est pas chasseur
cueilleur voyons si vous n'êtes pas de
remettre en cause un milieu les gens qui
veulent aussi je comprends bien que vous
vous ayez une approche alors jugé j'ai
vu que la dernière fois je dis quand on
votre grand mère a tué un poulet je
voulais trouver ça horrible et donc ça
vous a marqué vous êtes passé
moi ma grammaire tuer des lapins glv des
canards je n'ai jamais eu ce problème là
je tenais les pattes du lapin quand elle
l'a nettoyé on le mange et je les soigne
important pendant des mois on s'amuse
avec je n'ai pas le même recul que vous
par rapport à la souffrance animale à
l'utilité de pouvoir nager des reculs ou
de non je n'ai pas la même approche que
vous et je trouve que moi mon approche
elle est aussi bien s'est fondée parce
que ce que je fais dans la nature je
l'assumé pleinement je préfère tuer ma
maman d'animal et le consommer que de
dire je vais l'acheter ou un poulet
l'égalité ou alors encore moins manger
cellulaire excusez moi ce que vous allez
manger de la viande qu acheter qui a été
levée j'ai un circuit court à côté de
chez moi j'ai quelques fermes qui vont
très bien je vais vous dire que les
animaux je sais we saw et le morceau
comme généralement animaux et tabac
localité on va faire une pause mais
l'amour dans les propos là de notre
interlocuteur on voit très bien que la
notion d'éthique n'apparaît pas
puisqu'il va baser son expérience sur
son ressenti il ne voit pas de problème
a tué à la paille ne vois pas de
problème à tuer assure mal or le propre
de l'éthique c'est de prendre en compte
le point de vue de l'autre celui qui va
bientôt lui et messieurs d'éviter des
problèmes de le tuer abbas et la
question est en fait monsieur à brioude
merron dans l'équation mais l'animal
l'animal bien sûr il ne veut pas
souffrir il veut pas se faire voler une
question qui aime pas la route mais vous
voulez tout rôle est d'organiser tous
très lentement de guerre de la nature
toute la cité si nous avions une pie en
train de chauffer le la peine sans
jamais parler sur vous avez relatio de
la veyron la grand mère allumez le coup
du lapin dit que ça s'appelle comme ça
et tout le monde le sait donc pour faire
la mort la plus rapide les anciens tuer
le lapin il mettait un coup des
réalisateurs bac c'était vite fait on le
mange est d'accord c'est propre c'est
fait vous observez une pique qui veut
tuer un napperon ses propres défis une
famille du point de vue de la beauté
moins bien je dis bien une pile dans la
nature c'est ce que c'est qu'une pige
pas si vous êtes en ito log elle veut
attraper un lapin mais comme les lapins
il est un peu gros pour elle sait
comment il va les tuer à 28 ans du creux
dans les yeux pour athènes son cerveau
je vous êtes vous garantis que la
souffrance n'est hélas alors vous parlez
d'éthique dans la nature voulait
réinventer les animaux voulait que lyon
dimanche plus de gaz elle voulait que le
héros ne détruit plus il attrapé des
cartes comme ça qui s'est pas manger
voulait avoir un ordre mondial
différente de ce que nous vivons
aujourd'hui nos propres l'homme
aujourd'hui il est suffisamment
intelligent suffisamment bien pour
pouvoir réguler les espèces en tuer les
consommer et que la maltraitance et la
cruauté animale elle a toujours été
condamné parce que là il ya un vrai
problème lorsqu'on et tortionnaires
animaux mais pas sur le phénomène de
chasse et de pêcher aujourd'hui vous
êtes je voulais tout interdire vous êtes
les dangers ration incroyable je vous
interromps tous les deux ont fait une
pause et je leur donne la parole thomas
lepeltier
[Musique]
nouvelle hausse de 12 6% pour les prix
du gaz au 1er octobre du côté des
carburants ce n'est pas mieux qu'à part
redonner un peu de marge pour pouvoir
d'achat l'exécutif est complètement
impuissant non les tailles vous fait pas
cadeau l'état c'est nous donc on se fait
des cadeaux à nous mêmes le problème
c'est que ça ne résout pas le problème
c'est le décale il faut qu'il fasse
quelque chose de visible et baisser une
taxe n'est pas visible en revanche vous
envoyez un chèque ces visites c'est pas
quand les matières premières explosent à
la hausse qu'il faut se poser la
question c'est avant tout gouverner
c'est prévoir mais c'est pas seulement
prévoir sa réélection
[Musique]
pourquoi la guinée reste engluée dans
cette spirale de coups d'état depuis
l'indépendance jusqu'à présent on était
dans le même cycle politique un état
répressif des élites porté vers la
corruption vers le détournement de
deniers publics
une volonté de confisquer les attributs
de l'ensemble de la souveraineté c'est
l'adn de la classe politique qui a pris
la place du collège jusqu'à présent le
coup d'état du 5 septembre n'a pas
surpris est-ce que c'était prévisible
pour vous également tu était tout à fait
prévisible
puis deux années même avec monsieur
alpha condé deux pays étaient dans une
crise profonde à la fin de son second
mandat il a cherché nous pas tous les
moyens y compris des moyens tout à fait
inadmissible à se maintenir au pouvoir
[Musique]
on reprend notre débat avec hélène tweak
est présidente co-présidente du parti
animalistes est candidate à la prochaine
élection présidentielle
eddie puyjalon quel président du
mouvement de la ruralité avec thomas
lepeltier qui est chercheur en éthique
animal et christophe baticle qui est
socio anthropologue alors le débat bat
il est là où il est depuis un certain
temps entre les défenseurs des animaux
qui veulent qu'on arrête tout bonnement
de tuer les animaux et les chasseurs qui
se présentent eux aussi comme des
défenseurs des animaux des défenseurs de
la nature et même des défenseurs de l'
humanité éternelle qui a toujours
chasser et tuer des animaux la parole
est à vous thomas lepeltier oui mais je
pense qu'il faut se rendre compte que la
société a évolué depuis quelques
décennies et que maintenant nous sommes
à un niveau où quelque part tout le
monde n'accepte plus la violence à
l'encontre des animaux on n'accepte plus
de faire souffrir et de tuer un animal
pour le plaisir ça peut être le cas il
ya quelques siècles c'était même le cas
à l'encontre des humains on pouvait
accepter la souffrance contre des
humains pour le plaisir mais nous
n'acceptons plus cette violence et cette
souffrance contre les animaux la grande
question c'est que maintenant on a on
refuse celle là et elle se perpétue
toujours alors elle se perpétue déjà
bien sûr dans les abattoirs en france
puisque on tue 3 millions d'animaux
alors il faut savoir ce que ça veut dire
tu es 3 millions d'animaux dans les
abattoirs ce sont les égorger d'accord
on égorge 3 millions d'abattoirs dans
les animaux juste pour des plaisirs
gustatifs puisque c'est juste une
fonction de plaisir de manger de la
viande est là puisque le point de la
chasse nous internet achat de loisirs
c'est à les tuer et souvent quand on
tuer les animaux à la chasse on les fait
souffrir pour le plaisir donc il ya un
décalage énorme entre l'évolution de la
société qui de façon pour l'instant
accord très théorique n'accepte plus le
faire souffrir et de tuer des animaux
pour le plaisir et des pratiques qui se
perpétue et qui doit bien sûr un jour
arrêter de continuer puisque ça ne
correspond plus je dirais à la morale de
la société et monsieur puel ont dit ils
ne voient pas la souffrance il ne voit
pas la cruauté mais ne pas voir la
cruauté ne veut pas dire qu'il n'ya pas
de cruauté on voit de la cruauté le jour
où on se met g1 quand on prend le point
de vue de l'animal l'animal qui se fait
tirer dessus l'animal qui se fait pour
choix pour chasser quand c'est la chasse
à courre sont des animals qui sont en
souffrance sont des animaux des animaux
terroriser et je pense qu'il y a de la
cruauté dans les appartements où on se
met du point de vue de l'animal et je
pense que ça c'est le propre c'est le
propre de l'éthique de se mettre à la
place de la victime et appartements où
on se met à la place de la victime je
pense que vous pourrez tous est d'accord
pour se dire ne faisons pas souffrir et
ne tuons pas des animaux quand ce n'est
pas nécessaire
le stock baticle alors plusieurs points
le premier je suis un petit peu désolé
du coup d'avoir fait détourner le débat
sur les chasseurs cueilleurs ce que je
pense qu'effectivement et merci à mon
cher collègue d'avoir rappelé le fait
que la question de fond c'est celle du
plaisir ou du nom plaisir autrement dit
c'est une question qui est moral le
deuxième point c'est que les philosophes
nous ont montré que dans les années 1960
on pensait que tout était politique et
peut-être raison mais ce n'est pas là et
ont considéré que la morale était une
vieille lune qu'il fallait jeter aux
orties aujourd'hui on a inversé les
choses on considère que c'est la morale
qui va faire office de politique donc il
ya une vrai débat à avoir là-dessus est
ce qu'on peut faire avec la morale de la
politique maintenant ce qui est certain
ce qui me semble évident c'est que et
élage masque rend fou sur le term
evolution qui est revenue deux fois dans
ton discours deux fois tu vas parler
d'évolution et moi ça me fait toujours
un petit peu peur en tant que ce jeune
anthropologue parce que derrière il ya
l'évolutionnisme et je ne suis pas
convaincu que l'histoire est un sens et
là on est encore une fois sur un débat
de fond est ce que l'histoire a un sens
et est ce que donc nous aurions le sens
de l'histoire
le sens le transcrire par je suis revenu
sur le sens de l'histoire et puis après
je vous répondre non il y a un sens au
centre on peut constater une évolution
ces dernières décennies oui à de cette
question le fait que la question animale
et émerger le fait que nous soyons là
réunis ce n'est pas pour rien c'est
parce que la question animale maintenant
est au coeur de la société un certain
nombre d'années de plus en plus
d'individus se demande est ce que le
rapport que l'on aux animaux est
justifiée est-ce qu'on peut perpétuer ce
rapport qu'on a aux animaux qui est
basée en grande partie sur la violence
je rappelle lé chiffre de 3 millions
d'animaux qui sont égorgés jeudi je
répète le mot à escient égorger tous les
jours dans les abattoirs c'est une
question de plus en plus de français sur
la pose à quoi ça sert ça sert juste à
faire plaisir à se faire plaisir et ça
les gens hors médecins en cause et la
chasse bien sûr elle rentre dans sept
ans remise en cause allez faire de la
chasse pour le plaisir c'est bien ça qui
est au coeur du sujet c est quand on
parle de tradition quand on parle de
tradition je fais les remparts la
tradition c'est bien exister une
tradition c'est bien pour le plaisir
c'est pas une nécessité donc pourquoi
continuer à faire souffrir et à tuer des
animaux pour le plaisir je répète cette
question et j'attendrai une réponse
argumentée non pas parce que ça me plaît
puisque la route diffusée vous avez beau
aligner les phrases avec une
intelligence incroyable je vais vous
répandre comme un bon terrien d'abord le
plaisir c'est pas négatif dans la vie et
lui avoir du plaisir c'est quelque chose
qui est qui émancipe d'abord ça me
permet d'être peut-être un peu moins
malade que certains j'ai pas besoin de
cacher j'ai rien besoin mal à mon avis
est équilibré j'ai un ratio est un
relationnel aux animaux qui me va très
bien la cruauté et c'est faire de la
souffrance par plaisir et faire durer
moi j'ai pas j'ai pas l'intention de
faire la cruauté j'ai pas l'impression
de faire la cruauté je fais pas souffrir
les animaux deuxièmement dans la nature
l'acte de chasse
aujourd'hui le ressenti que j'ai moins
chasseurs mais que mes collègues aussi
éleveur c'est que le discours que vous
avez assez light aujourd'hui mois celui
que je vois tous les jours c'est la
dérive totale c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui animalistes ne veulent
plus aucun ratio or un rapport l'animal
tire plus d'animaux domestiques peach up
y tient que des animaux sauvages qui ce
qui se peuvent vivre dans la nature
seule sans l'intervention de l'homme
vous avez une approche bien ces gens là
où une approche de l'animal roi et on
arrive à une société aujourd'hui où
madame connais très bien
je cite souvent l'exemple parce qu'il
m'a profondément marqué rue sainte
catherine à bordeaux une dame âgée plus
de 80 ans qui fait la manche avec un
petit tablier est là la souffrance sur
elle mais je vois plein d'humanité en
elle il ya plus personne qui donne un
euro et plus loin vous avez quelques
skins est qu'ils ont fait un choix de
vie marginal qui en trois chiens donner
à manger aux chiens mettez de l'argent
les gens donnent pour les chiens
c'est cette société que je refuse
aujourd'hui c'est aujourd'hui je crois
qu'il ya un équilibre entre les animaux
et les humains mais on est en train de
basculer par la pression médiatique des
animalistes des écologistes qui ont bien
compris qu'aujourd'hui s'occuper des
oiseaux il ya plus martreuil vivant
c'est tous les vivants donc on est
maintenant rendu sur la punaise de lit
sur les puces sur les poules sur
l'éthique fait je sais plus où on va
arriver aujourd'hui ou non humains et
vaut mieux quand se flinguent dès le
matin parce que tout ce qu'on fait c'est
culpabilité je ne culpabilise pas je
suis certain que de nombreux gens comme
moi dans la nature chasseurs pêcheurs
cueilleurs nous sommes pleinement notre
place dans la nature pleinement notre
place dans la société on fait du bien on
essaie d'être interventionnistes alors
il faut le faire mais on n'est pas être
au banc des accusés quand vous le dites
et puis excusez moi excusez moi j'ai pas
envie d'avoir du plaisir à manger de la
viande cellulaire demain j'ai mon propre
sang comme on est en train de le faire
ailleurs moi j'ai envie de continuer à
manger de la viande approché du foie
gras et j'adore mes jambes et du pays
basque des landes et croyez bien que
cette vie là elle n'est pas négative ô
combien ô combien pas négatif du tout je
crois qu'elle est même vecteur de
d'avenir peut-être de progrès parce
qu'on y reviendra les dix piges allons
il n'y a pas que les animals ici à walt
disney aussi walt disney a fait
énormément diliberto s'identifier aux
animaux mais c'est une évidence bambi
enfin je le lion qui parle à la gazelle
et qui va boire un coup à la campagne
avec excusez moi bambi ça n'existe pas
dans la nature malheureusement tous les
jours les loups aujourd'hui parler un
berger qui est qui et tous les jours
confronté à avoir de deux loups qui rend
dans une bergerie quand tu 30 qui laisse
des amis au sens guignon là à côté
desquels n'a pris qu'un pour manger ou
comme petits morceaux c'est la nature et
l l'animal nenê n'est pas là au niveau
de l'homme il ne réfléchit pas un renard
va détruire un poulailler inquiets et
des exemples comme ça j'en ai pléthore
mais il faut aussi vivre dans la nature
la nature n'est pas n'est pas ben oui
c'est quelque chose de plus alors
personne ne dit que la nature et bambi
et quand on vous entend vous parlez je
je je moi mon plaisir est ce que l'on
vous dit c'est que il faut pas
s'intéresser qu'à son plaisir mais à
prendre en compte aussi les conséquences
de ce que vous appelez votre président
est de faire au mieux et les animalistes
ou aussi ont du plaisir en ne massacrant
pas des animaux est votre conception de
votre rapport à la nature il faut quand
même aussi réfléchir sur le fait qu' il
a des conséquences extrêmement négatif
sur les animaux sur l'environnement les
tonnes de plomb qui sont déversées et
qu'il doit être interrogé mais vous êtes
persuadé de sa crypte être mais en tout
cas le débat caricatural et l'éthique
est caricatural selon lesquelles les
animalistes privilégie les animaux aux
humains bien c'est faux mais c'est faux
que tel et écouter les valley ma liste
de quelques jeunes que mes problèmes
avec les humains non mais moi j'ai une
amie 4 janvier mais c'est une caricature
maintenant la vie humaine
mais si mauvaise et l'orient n'est pas
du vent mais pas dur il aurait non mais
gilbert et capturer la plupart des
animalistes précisément ci s'intéresse
aux animaux si l'on élargit le champ
leur considération morale on sait que
évidemment madame le doyen ne vivrai
animalistes mais les mavs et l'analyse
d'échantillons
non merci non non non mais vous essayez
d'en fermer le débat la réalité c'est
cool je le remets dans le concept où il
est aujourd'hui réalité des gens qui
n'arrivent pas le contraire non c'est
faux je cherche la plupart des
animalistes sont au contraire très
préoccupé par les causes humaines et
sont beaucoup plus engagée pour les
causes humaines que ne sent la plupart
lorsque vous on n'est pas conséquent ces
tours quelques humaines vous êtes malade
ou pas du tout mon cas de succès même si
l'intérêt pour les chasseurs des
pollutions alors que ceux qui polluent
le jeu longtemps une telle vision
puisque les animalistes sont pas
engageants les humains pour quelle cause
etes-vous humains nous avait une théorie
soit sur moi qui achètent par les rayons
de la vente et salomé 69 kg aux régimes
dans les éoliennes les aigles et cetera
les buses les millions d'oiseaux et ça
ne me pose pas de problème le chasseur
qui serait de ne pas si mal fait ou pas
un problème mais parce que la
technologie l'évolution les grandes
sociétés qui polluent par tout ça ça me
prenait si on a bien sûr que ça passe et
programmatique passer un petit peu vite
sur un postulat qu'on l'a acceptée qui
consisterait à penser que allah y aurait
d'un côté ceux qui tueraient pour
s'alimenter et de l'autre côté ceux qui
tueraient pour leur plaisir moi je me
demande si le plaisir a pas toujours été
à l'origine des pratiques de chasse y
compris il ya très longtemps de ça c'est
une question et je ne dis pas que c'est
bien ou mal c'est pas dans ce jugement
de valeur j'ai pas dans la morale je me
pose simplement la question est ce qu'on
est certain qu'ils compris à l'ère
préhistorique
on pense à certains travaux de collègues
on ne chassait pas pour le plaisir en
grande partie en tout cas pour ce bien
faire voir en tout cas ce pour se
valoriser à cet éminent au moins une
chaleur l'image d'un pollution d'un
chasseur blanc en afrique posant ce coup
je sais pas si ce temps d'afrique ne
devait pas être un tifo mais si c'est un
tigre salut être en inde en tout cas on
va l'avoir voilà on le voit mal non ce
doit être une lionne et il doit être en
afrique mais au kenya et puis on voyait
aussi des masaï à peu près la même
époque le chassant avec leurs lances on
peut imaginer que les bassins ne
mangeait pas lyon qu'ils étaient en
train de chasser donc c'était aussi pour
se prouver quelque chose kylie kylie
kylie tu as eu pas possible la défense
et marc fosset la défense il ya pu avoir
du plaisir dans les châssis il ya
longtemps quand les êtres humains
chassait pour se nourrir et qui est dur
mais on y allait pour se nourrir depuis
la belgique risque inverse c'est là
qu'ils ont c'est fini on sait pas il n'y
a pas que la question du plaisir il ya
la question de la nécessité serre que
maintenant c'est facultatif c'est pas
que si on chassait il ya dix mille ans
et on y trouvait du plaisir c'était
aussi une nécessité parce qu'on n'avait
pas trouvé d'autres moyens de se nourrir
maintenant c est facultative et c'est ça
la grande crise et n'est pas une
nécessité donc peut-on encore se
permettre je repose la question puisque
monsieur ne veut pas il répondu
suscitant accord se permettent dans
notre société où comment plutôt je
reviens sur les cadeaux comment
justifier que l'on fasse souffrir et
qu'on tue des animaux uniquement pour
son plaisir c'est la question à laquelle
un jeu fini je m'étais déjà d'agoria
c'est la question de viande de boucherie
la question à laquelle la société ne
veut pas répondre et c'est l'éléphant au
milieu de la salle personne ne veut
répondre à cette question éthique toute
simple comment on justifie le fait qu on
tue qu'on fasse souffrir les animaux
pour son plaisir ou là j'attends un
arnaud et non pas et non pas avait déjà
exigé que j'aime c'est même pas la peine
de discuter vous vous renier même le
fait de pouvoir voir des animaux tués à
l'abattoir donc la seule sommation
carnet vous la remettez en cause que les
facteurs d'accidents que écouter à
partir ce moment là c'est pas la peine
je vous suis ch'ti fils acte de chasse
c'est la même chose que l'acte du
boucher alors vu des données moins
justifiées moi l'acte de mèche
elle et elle est facultative
appartements ont trop des compléments
alimentaires du tout avec le tpiy n'est
pas là c'est pas du tout on n'a pas
besoin de prendre des compléments
alimentaires la notion de compléments
alimentaires c'est quelque chose une
espèce de fumisterie compte qu'on met en
avant pour faire peur du végal pas
d'erreur véganisme on peut se nourrir
gers en complément alimentaire faut
arrêter avec cette idée il ya toujours
derrière uniquement de derb et deux oui
les
compétences et les talents c'est que les
légumineuses ces céréales très variés la
finalité c'est la vienne au cellulaire
mais non là sinon je suis les gens
tensions financières dans les chariots
et lunaire la viande et du lait ont
également très bien y a pas de gens de
ses livres directement les mégane vivent
très bien donc c'est un autre débat on
pourra faire une émission sur suivant
c'est trop je ne fais pas la question la
notion de complément c'est quelque chose
qui n'a pas de sens veut dire par
exemple de notre société on va prendre
deux llyod à travers le sel circuit ya
une recommandation est une
recommandation de l'état de mètres de
lieu dans le seul parce que c'est
autrement beaucoup de français
n'auraient pas assez d'autres est ce
qu'on va parler ce qu'on va dire que les
omnivores se complémentent en iode non
c'est exactement la même façon donc
effectivement dans une alimentation il
faut s'arranger pour qu'on est tous les
nutriments nécessaires
donc on s'arrange pour avoir les
nutriments nécessaires et ongles
délégation royale tout le monde en a
besoin d'être un chemin lepeltier
reconnaissez que dans la société vega
l'idéal on ne doit plus voir des animaux
parce qu'on aurait pu en des
propriétaires on pourrait plus élevés
ont pointé les faire travailler les
enfants on aurait pu aller manger donc
on aurait pu les arrêter en arrivent à
leur laisser des territoires entiers
rien sauvage zorro des réserves à un
endroit et puis on n'aura pas le droit
d'y aller sinon ça c'est un espèce de
fontana le buteur des animaux donc la
plupart des contacts et les français
avec des animaux de nos jours c'est des
contacts avec des animaux de compagnie
d'abord ça c'est de la balle de
chasseurs serein car je serais
aujourd'hui sérieusement une partie des
adhérents et des animations des animaux
comme l'express d'un animal ne les voit
pas ils sont tous dans des bâtiments
fermés donc faut arrêter cette espèce de
fantasme que les français seraient en
contact avec des mots 95% des animaux
que l'on mange salaire 3 millions
d'animaux tués par jour on ne les voit
jamais les seuls ennemis ou non et chats
sont nombreux cela on est chassé masson
pas de tous les animaux vous parlez de
la société vega donc 2 toute façon les
animaux qui ce qu'on dit être là ils ne
sont plus là dans le sens où ils sont
tous enfermés dans des bâtiments fermés
donc après je vois encore conscient il
m'a fait qu'il y aurait moins de vaches
dans les champs puisque l'evalia marée
bleue du tout n'aurait pu qu on pourrait
regarder quelques-unes dans des refuges
n'est pas une obsession la question
fondamentale c'est est ce qu'il est
légitime acharnée au moral pour avoir le
plaisir de voir des vaches dans son tgv
je l'entends de massacrer des millions
de vaches passons là c'est la vraie
société pour pouvoir les garder pour
pouvoir les garder dans l'échangé et
morales qu'il ait tué des millions de
barils à chaque année d'accord mais je
sais que c'est pas entre la paix et la
guerre sept autres le fait qu'on les tue
mais qu'on les a sous les yeux et quand
même pas loin de nous et le fait qu' ils
ne sont plus là bas les gens vivent plus
loin sur les questions quand même à
poser un vrai mais la question du besoin
et du désir en fait jusqu'à maintenant
on n'avait pas trop aborder cette
question fondamentale besoin ou désir
nécessité ou plaisir en fait il me
semble on peut se poser la question de
savoir si nos sociétés sont plutôt géré
par le besoin ou par le désir comment
nous arbitrons les deux ça ça me semble
être une question fondamentale qu'on l'a
pas posée et je ne suis pas certain que
ce soit ou mais le vote donne encore le
fait d'avoir envie que les animaux
restent pas trop loin nous que ce soit
dans des champs ou sur des trottoirs
tenus en laisse c'est un besoin ou un
désir alors ce qui est certain par
contre c'est que nous vivons avec nos
besoins nos désirs sont gérés par le
système dans lequel nous vivons on
appelle ça le capitalisme or il ya quand
même cette question fondamentale qui est
posée
qui est cette course au profit qui amène
effectivement aujourd'hui à des
conditions animalière qui choque je me
souviens pas que pendant les 70 ans de
communisme en union soviétique les
problèmes preuve des animaux était
traité différemment si on râle de
staline comme étant un anti capitaliste
effectivement je suis tout jeune papa
gabriel pas entendre capitaliste
et pas si le productivisme soviétique et
est enviable au productivisme allways
cet autre qui est d'accord autre chose
le productivisme n'est pas la partie la
vache n'est pas le même que sur lui sur
la partie demain viennent de synthèse
non mais le capitalisme ne fait pas de
différence il fait du profit exactement
pour revenir sur la question quand même
de la chasse parce que c'est une
question qu'on a un peu évacuer
rapidement vous expliquer tout à l'heure
la chasse avec cette communion avec la
nature c'est un petit peu l'image que
l'on sent laquelle les sociétés dans
votre peinture un peu idyllique des
rapports avec la nature une mystifié
comment vous expliquer ces 20 millions
d'animaux qui sont élevés ils sont
lâchés réserver ces brigands mai et moi
j'habite à la campagne the west et
faisant ce qu'ils voient ça le même pas
se déplacer qui sont au milieu de la
route comment vous justifiez ça tâter
pas un rapport avec la nature je vais je
vais vous expliquer d'abord un je
préfère que le chasseur et tu es s'en
faisant même d'élevage la chaîne juste
devant lutter plutôt d'aller chercher un
poulet de mauvaise qualité ça n'empêche
pas les alertes écoutez moi je vous dis
ce que je considère plutôt pas mal
ensuite il ya des endroits mêmes où on
tue des faisans d'élevage d'abord je
vous invite à regarder les élevages
plutôt que de faire des montages vidéos
sont des élevages de qualité en plein
air je vois les élevages et sylvain
porte je vous le dis moi et secundo il
ya des personnes âgées des chasseurs qui
sont contents de pouvoir tuer en faisant
comme ça de rentrer avec son chien de le
consommer je vais vous dire rien de son
sourire son plaisir ça me suffit à moi
comme pour mon moteur exactement vous
voyez les choses d'une façon arbitraire
vous voyez de la souffrance par tous et
bienvenue moi je vous dis que ce soit de
l'élevage
on en rirait je me fais dire qu'ils
prélèvent un animal d'élevage j'ai pas
dit prévenant la joie pour maintenir des
souches locales et sauvage connaissait
de réimplanter parce que malheureusement
et malgré les efforts des chasseurs il
ya certaines espèces qui disparaissent
aujourd'hui parler mais fier de notre
société actuelle et pour laquelle les
chasseurs sont vraiment impliqués
élevé millions d'animaux vous allez
salut en tribunal et quid de nature ya
passé mais non mais non ça au sérieux
encore une fois de plus c'est tu essaies
munger s'est consommé s'est fait
proprement ça vous voulez quoi peut-être
mais moi je trouve que
vous avez un rapport aux animaux et de
toute manière je comprends aujourd'hui
d'être dérive c'est du végétal manger
des carottes et les machins écoutez je
mangerai pas d'écarter les machins je
veux qu'ils aient des poissons dans
l'eau donc je me bats pour
l'environnement je veux que des animaux
et les oiseaux dans les arrivées voulais
je mets mon rapport de prélèvement je le
vois comme le chasseur intelligents les
films de comment il s'appelle le le dr
le dernier trappeur le
comment il s'appelle jeremiah johnson
non non non le ratio du dugas quittera
peur mais qui prend quelques animaux et
en même temps qu'un espoir aux arbres ou
tablette dicaprio c'est un peu piqué
mais si vous voulez c'est ça la gestion
la gestion intelligente de la nature
c'est ce que pratique et est d'abord
parce qu'on a on a besoin d'être d'abord
en étant des règles extrêmement sérieuse
les ministères etc ils ont ce nous mêmes
notre intelligence à nous c'est d'être
interpellé parce que aujourd'hui voyez
on voit moins de deux papillons moins
d'insectes envoient moins d'oiseaux
protégés c'est chaud qui disparaissent
le plus aujourd'hui les espèces qui
dépasse la plus jolie ce sont celles qui
sont non chassés et d'ailleurs
j'expliquais papa blanc que la chasse à
une plus value là dessus parce que
généralement on évite d'avoir des
maladies en puissance où on enlève les
oiseaux les plus faibles et donc
généralement on a une espèce qui se
porte très bien vous vous inquiétez pas
de savoir ce qui se passe et des
oestrogènes des gens les sous les
produits toxiques qui sont grosso mais
tout ça va dans l'eau aujourd'hui des
poissons sainte lucie en mâles et
femelles mais on fout le lol le le
cachet sur le pêcheur ou le chasseur non
madame non madame aujourd'hui ceux qui
sont là pour protéger la nature mais qui
la vivent pleinement et qui ont du
plaisir peut protéger pas les chasseurs
les pêcheurs sont tués tous les ans je
m'en moque évidemment voir partage on
est d'accord sur le fait moi je vois des
choses que j'ai de cajou partagent un
bout de viande avec os rêver des copains
et je vois aujourd'hui en restaurants
maquis qui va très bien à ce moment
golts ont écouté les gueuletons ça veut
dire quelque chose mais les gens
prennent du plaisir retrouvé un boulet
bien oui il est bien écouter tant qu'on
pourra le faire moi j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on va réchauffer la
planète avec deux bouts de viande par
contre si on peut arrêter les grands
paquebots qui plaisent plus que le temps
mis pour lui
certaines à 32 bateaux qui peut lui
autant que toutes les voitures du monde
faudrait peut-être arrêter le commerce
international est la chine etc et
revenir du plus simple chasseurs
pêcheurs cueillant dans sa nature la
ceinture
et diffuser langonnais 12 lentement la
nature mais il ya eu quand même pendant
très très longtemps quand on était
chasseur on prenait le risque de se
faire tuer par sa proie
moi j'ai un arrière grand père qui était
chasseur on l'a retrouvée au pied de
l'arbre éventrée par le sanglier il
avait raté bien jouer sangliers ne l'a
pas ne l'a bien raté est ce que il
manque pas justement une dimension
aujourd'hui c'est quand même assez rare
à notre époque qu'un chasseur français
c'est assez singulier c'est comme un
sérieux dilemme faire simple il prend
entre les cuisses et si leurs terres
voilà d'accord donc les morts on les
connaît on vous dira le ratio il est
comme ça ça fait partie chose on n'est
pas honteux ne sait pas travailler des
ours mais ça existe aujourd'hui la
chasse à l'ours existe dans le nord de
l'europe et dans d'autres pays écoutez
on est en afrique et encore de la
régulation sur les grands animaux les
gens parlaient dc depuis paris parce
qu'ils ont une vision idyllique de
l'afrique sauf que là nous africains les
empires la manger quand sa cage ou leur
territoire en donner lorsqu'il ya un
éléphant qui a problem c'est comme pour
les louves aux états unis bah on tue sur
les animaux aujourd'hui c'est la
génétique les hippopotames l'amba en
afrique qui tue le même parce que ça
arrive aussi alors voilà mais ce sont
quand même des gestions avec les
populations humaines a considéré qu on
fait disparaître l'homme est donc
certain sommes pas loin aujourd'hui moi
c'est pas ma vision des choses voilà oui
aujourd'hui le ratio d'abord j'ai plutôt
et je dirais oui la condition animale
d'accord mais à la condition humaine
d'abord je me veux plutôt une
alternative mais c'est non non non parce
que quand vous voyez un des villages en
afrique où les sages de la mer oui mais
elle est la gironde dont on vient même
chose madame c'est la même chose vous ne
concevait pas l'intervention de l'homme
dans la nature et j'ai réussi mais non
non non non bien sûr facile mais on
n'avait pas trop expliquer que dans la
durée sont positives a pas tardé mais
ruraux une très bonne relation avec les
chasseurs parce que je me sens très
régressive écoutez
bien vous y êtes avec le sondage qui
c'est qui s'occupe de faire du social
nous de faire de l'entretien est hérissé
voir union relationnel avec rené
siphonner sparfel et ses futures est
claire mercereau en ont marre non pas du
tout mais bien sûr
alors il nous reste quelques minutes
christophe bétique de batik le pardon et
thomas lepeltier bas on a oublié quelque
chose mais on ne peut pas traiter tout
on a parlé de la mort beaucoup la mort
physique pourrait peut-être est en aussi
parce qu'on peut mourir physiquement on
peut mourir symboliquement les gens qui
nous écoutent en ce moment qu'ils sont
plus très vivant finalement ce qu'ils
ont été tuées symboliquement alors ça
concerne de ce qu'on en connaît bien sûr
surtout des êtres humains aujourd'hui
mais je pense que ça serait utile
d'introduire cette notion parce que on
parle de mort comme si elle était unie
comme si elle était évidente c'est quand
le coeur s'arrête 1 il ya bien d'autres
manières de mourir et puis ce qui me
vient à l'esprit en ce sens va le dire
pour les animaux comme tous les autres
humains pas et peut-être en tout cas
j'ai pas témoignage en la matière c'est
ce qui me pose problème géopolitique par
contre il ya aussi la question de la
bonne mort finalement alors je mets ça
entre guillemets parce que on pourrait
me répondre n'ya pas de bonne mort il ya
que de mauvaises mains aujourd'hui oui
mais faut pas oublier qu'à d'autres
époques non seulement agonir dans une
conception monothéistes chrétienne par
exemple c'était gagné sa passion gagner
son paradis mais on avait aussi cette
idée que agonir c'était un moyen de
préparer la succession mon avis il ya eu
dans l'histoire de l'humanité il ya
encore différentes manières d'envisager
la question de la bonne mort et ça on
l'a pas abordé peut-être débat thomas
lepeltier je pense le débat souvent se
focalise entre des forces d'opposition
il y aurait d'un côté la ruralité puis
en face les animalistes qui ne
connaîtraient rien à la nature ou ne
voudrais pas intervenir dans la nature
comme ça vient d'être dit je pense qu'il
faut voir au contraire l'analyse comme
un désir d'intervention de la nature du
soin de la nature dans la nature il ya
un certain nombre d'animaux et les
animistes prennent en compte ces animaux
prennent en compte la lie la qualité de
vie de ces animaux le bien-être de ces
animaux est quelque part il y aura donc
un désir d'intervention dans la nature
et je pense qu'il pourrait y avoir des
alliances entre les ruraux ce qu'on
appelle les ruraux les gens qui vivent
donc à proche de la nature il ré des
alliances possibles pour gérer cette
nature mais que cette gestion de la
nature se base pas sur la mort
systématique quelque part que la mort ne
soit que le dernier recours de il ya
effectivement peut-être des situations
où la gestion de la faune
ne peut se faire que par la violence à
ce moment là la chasse serait pour
potentiellement justifier ce qui est
dérangeant d'un point de vue animalistes
c'est que ça se fasse uniquement pour le
plaisir la chasse que ce soit juste une
activité de loisir de 2 juste quelque
part un petit je pourrais me permettre
un petit caprice c'est vrai de le
plaisir d'aller tuer un animal et le
plaisir de le ramener on pourrait très
bien imaginer je vais une alliance moi
et moi c'est ce que je voudrais une
alliance entre les animalistes et les
ruraux pour la gestion du territoire et
la gestion de la faune et je pense qu'il
n'y a pas d'impossibilité si quelque
part on met un petit peu des règles
éthiques c'est à dire ce que vous avez
la ligne après si on m'avait dit qu'on
ne tue pas on ne tue pas pour le plaisir
c'est une nature en cas de nécessité à
ce moment là je pense qu'il y aura un
dialogue qui pourrait cesser là c'est là
où le débat est impossible et c'est là
où j'ai essayé de discuter par exemple
avec allain bougrain dubourg ya 20 ans
il avait exactement les mêmes propos que
vous enlevez de réunion avait toute la
représentation l'état etc s'il avait il
a dit je considère qu'on ne peut pas
retirer la vie par plaisir donc fin des
discussions il n'ya plus avoir de
discussions sur la gestion des
territoires aux plantes et d arriver à
faire quelque chose d'intelligent il
considère un pour le vivant le le
retirer la vie par plaisir c'est pas
possible et donc vous voyez la
discussion va s'arrêter là parce que
c'est pas du tout mon coeur s'est arrêté
pas de la démocratie et que les citoyens
veulent que ça s'arrête donc citoyens
qui
innove qui met les ans une majorité de
citoyens belges que sa fille mais non
pas du tout il faut leur donner la
parole non un dernier mot c'est
formidable parce que mon collègue j'ai
tout dis parce que tu parlais très vite
voulu dire animalistes elle est très
vite d'avis animiste commencer ce que
j'ai entendu et je pense que le débat il
est là retrouve effectivement
l'animisme mais une version plutôt qui
répond peut centrer on est on est dans
un débat là qui est très clair je pense
dernier mot de conclusion il entre oui
effectivement je pense que il
il y à une imposture avec la chasse où
on essaie de l'assimiler à la rue
réalité la chasse non ce n'est pas la
ruralité la majorité des citoyens
veulent sortir de la chasse et il ya des
solutions même pour les dégâts aux
cultures même pour cette fameuse
régulation qui sont non préjudiciable
aux animaux c'est les mesures que l'on
porte merci tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]